in this video I want to talk about
protein structure specifically an
introduction to the levels of protein
structure so we talked about proteins in
biochemistry a lot and it's important to
understand how they work and we
mentioned earlier in a previous video or
previous videos that proteins are made
up of amino acids and the reason why we
mentioned that is because if we want to
know how proteins work then we should
probably know how they how they look and
hell out what their structure is like
because we know as a theme in just in
biology or science in general that
structure determines function
so within protein structure and we're
talking about the levels of protein
structure there are four levels primary
secondary tertiary and quaternary and I
want to introduce you to those here so
the first is primary generated by this
one and a little degree symbol here so
primary structure primary structure is
quite simply the order of amino acid the
amino acid sequence okay
the amino acid sequence in a polypeptide
chain so we mentioned polypeptides
before and that's just the term used to
describe a bunch of different amino
acids linked together via peptide bonds
so primary structure is simply the amino
acid sequence or the order of amino acid
the order in which amino acids are
linked
alright the order in which amino acids
are linked together okay so what's
important to keep in mind about the
primary structure well the primary
structure in essence determines
overall 3d structure of a protein and
initially hearing that might be kind of
weird might be tough to understand but
hopefully through through watching these
videos it'll make more sense but this
determines the overall 3d structure so
and another thing that you should keep
in mind about it is that the primary
sequence or the primary structure the
sequence of amino acids is read from the
red as in the color red it is read from
the amino terminus right from n to C or
from the amino terminus to the carboxy
terminus right so just to kind of give
you an idea about what this primary
structure sort of idea entails think
about it this way is that if we have
let's say we have a few different amino
acids so we have let's see let's say we
have asparagine we have glycine we have
histidine we have lysine we have leucine
and we have alanine let's say we have
these six amino acids okay so there can
be two different scenarios right or
there could be actually a variety of
scenarios but imagine these two for
instance so let's say we have the amino
terminus here right and we got a link
these six amino acids okay so let's say
we just link them actually in that order
let's see n G H K L a we link them all
via peptide bonds and then we have a
carboxy terminus here okay that could be
one potential peptide but we could have
another peptide using those same amino
acids right instead of having it in this
order we could have it has G n LH ka
right now these are both structured
differently and if they end up you know
folding upon themselves you can imagine
you know obviously that plays have ties
could be much much longer than this but
you can imagine that once these fold
upon them
the fact that they're ordered in this
different way might have a you know an
effect on how these peptides will look
when they fold so even though these two
peptides had the same exact amino acid
composition they will not look the same
overall on the 3d structure okay so
that's the whole idea behind primary
structure sort of determining what a
protein will look like okay that's in
essence what primary structure is all
about so let's talk about a secondary
structure so secondary structure what is
secondary structure so secondary
structure is the simplest way I think to
think about it is it's ordered patterns
ordered patterns of 3d arrangements this
might be a little bit technical just for
the time being
3d Arrangements on localized regions
localized regions of the backbone now
notice I'm all capping a backbone and
I'm even going to put a little red box
around it
and the reason why is because this just
keeping backbone in mind will help you a
great deal I feel in kind of remembering
what secondary structure is all about so
when when people think of secondary
structure as far as proteins go
they usually kind of just associate it
with hydrogen bonds right and that is a
correct Association so there are
hydrogen bonds that are involved in
secondary structure but in particular in
particular these hydrogen bonds that
we're talking about when we're talking
about secondary structure is hydrogen
bonds between this little BW here
between
the carbonyls carbonyl oxygens right and
the DM wide nitrogens hydrogen okay so
they're gonna be hydrogen bonds between
these carbonyl groups and these
hydrogen's here that are on the backbone
of the immuno IV at the amino acid the
polypeptide sequence and I'll kind of
draw this out to kind of explain what I
mean in just a second but there's one
more thing that people usually associate
with secondary structure and that's
alpha helix ease and beta pleated sheets
so I'll put alpha helix or alpha helix
ease alpha helix or a beta pleated sheet
now I'll talk more about this the
secondary structure just in general in
its own video it's a little bit more
complex than this as I want this to just
sort of function as a as a brief
introduction but let me kind of show you
what I mean by by this by this first
bullet point here these H bonds between
the carbonyl oxygens and the amide
hydrogen's so if we think about a short
polypeptide sequence let's just imagine
this we have you know our group of our
first amino acid here right and then
we'll have this going on here
it's then this peptide bond here right
and that's going to be this is gonna be
the next amino acid here right so this
is gonna have a be a different R group
so P hydrogen here this carbonyl here
another peptide bond hydrate night my
hydrogen there are these little
electrons not salts who necessary
there's some here as well oops okay and
this will be a third amino acid I'd off
there just through a safe time okay so
we have these three amino acids
connected here these two peptide bonds
so when we're talking about these
particular H bonds we're talking about
the H bonds that are existing
that exists between the backbone now
what what is the backbone I've mentioned
before maybe maybe not
that this whole idea of an NCC backbone
when it comes to polypeptides so let me
just write that up here actually so I'll
back the backbone is typically
considered L n si si oops let me
actually clean that up a little bit the
backbone is sort of NCC and then NCC it
repeats what people talk about the NCC
backbone when it comes to polypeptides
what are they really getting at they're
getting at the whole idea is that you
have nitrogen in the alpha carbon and
then the carbon carboxy carbon right
then it repeats each time so NCC and
then you've got another n C C and C C
and so on and so forth if there were
more amino acids in this chain so now
when we're talking about ordered
patterns of 3d arrangements of localized
regions the backbone I want you to
associate secondary structure with the
backbone specifically the carbonyls and
these uh these amide nitrogens here so
hydrogen bonds can exist for instance if
you have a long string of amino acid is
somehow bends back upon itself in either
an alpha helix or a beta pleated sheet
which again I will talk about in another
video there may be hydrogen bonds
between let's say like this is amino
acid number one is amino acid number two
three may be amino acid number 56 right
somehow you know in a beta pleated sheet
it's a my hydrogen becomes near this
this oxygen okay so they can hydrogen
bond let me draw it here although soon
this wouldn't necessarily make sense the
hydrogen bond that would that would
exist if would be between this this you
know this carbon eel group and another
amide hydrogen group so an h-bomb would
be something like this right between
them obviously and not in this case it
wouldn't actually happen again I want to
mention sort of details in the alpha
helixes and the way that we do see in
another video but the point is the
hydrogen bond
the hydrogen bonds that were
specifically concerned with when it
comes to secondary structure are the
ones that are involving this part of the
backbone okay that's very very important
to keep in mind as far as secondary
structure goes and the reason why is
because tertiary structure also includes
hydrogen bonds but the way those
hydrogen bonds that we're going to look
at are gonna be a little bit different
so let's actually talk about that let me
scroll down a little bit okay scroll
down okay so what about what is tertiary
structure then tertiary structure okay
what is their Surry structure so
tertiary structure is a little bit
different now I just mentioned that it
includes hydrogen bonds but you know
what what if three hydrogen bonds
if these hydrogen bonds along the
backbone are not included with what's
going on let's let this define tertiary
structure first so tertiary structure is
just the essentially V the the overall
3d arrangement of the protein okay
now this could include a bunch of
different things just kind of briefly
mention a few things this will have this
will involve a bunch of different things
including confirmations of the side
chains right it'll include the wrote the
like sort of the interactions between
the secondary structures that will
include relationships among and between
secondary structures and it could even
include prosthetic groups okay now what
are prosthetic groups prosthetic groups
are simply components of an of a protein
that are not amino acids so
nann amino acid components one quick
example that I can think of is uh
is the heme group in in hemoglobin okay
we'll talk about hemoglobin in a future
video as well so tertiary structure
includes a bunch of different things but
mostly mostly what I want you to
consider or sort of be concerned with is
is the this right here side chains okay
I want you to really concern yourself
with this side chains so why do I say
that it's because normally that's what
we're talking about I'm talking about
tertiary structure although of course
the overall 3d arrangement is the
definition and of course that involves a
bunch of different things but often
times when we're talking about choice
restructure we're considering the side
chains and how they're interacting with
each other so we have amino acid number
one and say amino acid number fifty in a
long chain maybe at some point when they
when the polypeptide folds upon itself
the R group from number one in a rash
with our group 50 and you know maybe
there's a hydrogen bond there that
hydrogen bond would be considered part
of tertiary structure not secondary
structure because it would be a hydrogen
bond between the side chains and not the
backbone so so let me kind of branch
this out really quickly this whole side
chains bit to kind of give you an idea
of what things you would be included
right when you're talking what sort of
interactions would you be considering
when when thinking about when you're
thinking about the side chains in
tertiary structure so there would be
hydrophobic interactions so so
hydrophobic groups will want to sort of
arrange with each other right so that's
the whole idea behind like dissolved
like so polar groups will want to be
close to polar groups and nonpolar
groups will want to be next to other
nonpolar groups so that that's that's
something to consider
our groups that are both non pole
want to associate with each other and
those that are polar will want to
associate with each other okay and we'll
talk about this in more depth later and
again I mentioned hydrogen bonds would
also be considered but specifically
these are hydrogen bonds between the
side chains right not the ones between
the backbone so if we had a serine for
instance which has an arguable ch2oh if
it happened to be next to another
another group like that maybe I happened
to be next to a tyrosine those those
hydroxyl groups could potentially
hydrogen bond together if they do that'd
be considered sort of under tertiary
structure another thing is the idea
behind electrostatic interactions and
again I want to just sort of reiterate I
will be talking about this in more
detail in its own video I don't want
this video to be an hour long so I'm
just introducing this right now so
electrostatic interactions interactions
and this is the whole idea between those
groups that have side chains that have
charges right so the acidic and basic
groups opposite charges will attract the
right if you have a positive group
together an acidic in the basic group
they'll be attracted to each other
those with like charges will repel so
there's no idea that charges play a role
in attraction and you know repulsion
between those side chains and the last
thing which i think is very very
important to remember we've mentioned it
earlier is that disulfide bridges so
this is between cysteine molecules right
and again we'll talk about how that's
that you do that covalent bond that can
be formed again that that's going to be
a classified under tertiary structure
okay more detail about these in their
own video I'll have a video specifically
for secondary structure and specifically
for tertiary structure because they're
far more complex than I can just talk
about here but this is a brief
introduction the last thing that I want
to mention is quaternary structure so
quaternary right structure what is
quaternary structure quite simply this
is just a bunch of if it is more than
one polypeptide chain involved in the
protein then that's that's that level
that you've reached is a quaternary
structure so this is just this is just
really multiple polypeptide chains
interacting so for instant example of
this could be like hemoglobin for
instance has four polypeptide units that
associate together that end up forming
one functional protein so that that the
highest level of structure that
hemoglobin has is quanta Neri whereas
myoglobin for example and again we'll
talk more about hemoglobin or myoglobin
later but the highest protein highest
level of structures that myoglobin has
because it only has one polypeptide is
tertiary right it doesn't have multiple
polypeptide units so this might seem
like a super simple definition here but
that really is all it that it is if a
protein has multiple polypeptide units
or polypeptide chains interacting to
form one functional protein and the
highest level of structure that that
protein has its quaternary structure
that pretty much wraps up the
introduction to protein structure again
I'll be talking about making more
specific videos about the details behind
secondary structure and tertiary
structure and I'll specifically talk
about Alpha helices beta pleated sheets
and all these different things here and
how you know how they work how they all
kind of draw them out for you to select
them that'll make sense and then I'll
also talk about how these things can be
disrupted how protein structure can be
disrupted so I hope that introduction to
protein structure sort of is a good one
and I'll bow is up for see you next time